und zwar wichtig heute galt über natalia
wörner die schauspielerin und die
lebensgefährtin von unserem
außenminister heiko matz und natalia
wörner in einem interview mit der bild
am sonntag gesagt dass sie nicht mit
ungeimpften drehen würde ich frage mich
wirklich geht's wo sind wir angekommen
in unserer zeit dass jetzt eine
schauspielerin mit dieser aussage
eigentlich will dass ungeimpfte
arbeitsverbot haben wir werden sie nicht
mit ungeimpften drehen will und ich
meine natalia wörner ist ja schon der
star einer jeden produktion da kann ich
mir schon vorstellen sich auch
durchsetzt das muss man sagen ein
produktionsbudget stark getestet testen
ist auch wichtig als zum beispiel
reproduktion jeden tag in schnelltest
und dann noch jeden zweiten tag den pcr
test der teil der berner ist es aber
nicht genug sie sagt für ungeimpfte gibt
es keine dreharbeiten mehr auf jeden
fall nicht wo sie teilnimmt sie wenig
mit ungeimpften drehen